okay before we go in remember you have
to pretend to be surprised how's this
oh my god it's so much worse than i
imagined
the energy was great but the message was
flawed all right let's get this over
with
surprise
what's going on i rented this entire bar
so you and i could celebrate with no
people anywhere near us probably should
have hired a bartender though i have no
idea how to make drinks this is
incredible
it's all charles's idea
i told you i knew you wrote row
thank you
but never call me roro again oh but i
will i've earned this
happy b day row row
diaz
pimento
what's up what's up with you
i need you to sign this report okay i'll
sign your report
what the hell
careful
the ink's still wet maybe this will help
okay they gotta knock that off loosen up
sard summer love baby it's march man
shut up
you punching holes
yeah that's way too much paper
not for me
can't even get a cup of coffee
[Applause]
well i'm off to find some yellow paper
so i can do this
all
over
again
all right diaz that's it
what's going on with you too oh you
noticed it yeah i noticed it everyone's
noticed it a convicted pervert asked me
if you guys could cool it i don't know
what to tell you something between us
sarge
something dark and urgent
i could have done that yeah i know you
could have but you didn't i did
i mean
there are lots of other poles guys
a whole street full of them
so adrian
i'm gonna stop messing around and do
this thing
uh
never what you know what i just realized
i i forgot something at home i'm just
gonna
that was weird you okay
yes something i'd like to say a pretty
private person so this is kind of hard
for me but
here we go
i'm bisexual all right i will now field
one minute and zero seconds of questions
pertaining to this go amy how long have
you known since seventh grade i was
watching saved by the bell and i thought
zack morris is hot and then i thought
at least a turtle also hot the fact that
the words kelly and kapowski didn't just
come out of your mouth is lunacy what
made you decide to tell us now charles
found out on the road trip and i was
positive he was not going to be able to
keep the secret for much longer bye rosa
i mean not bye but bye i mean see ya i
mean have fun only having sex with men
just banging dudes left and right i just
stopped saying bye all together so are
you seeing anyone now yeah her name's
tiffany are you lying about her name so
we won't look her up yes i am i want to
introduce you to my friend trishelle hi
sparks well i'm gonna take off you two
have fun good sub
i made a mobile version
so what are you drinking i'll have a
margarita but like a skinny margarita so
like tequila and lime and a tiny splash
of agave hmm i refuse to order that you
don't have to i heard her
what do you want just take your cheapest
whiskey and pour into your nearest glass
that's a drink so with this diet that
i'm on you can eat anything that's clear
like rice noodles pineapple gummy bears
so
how'd it get last night worst date i've
ever been on oh no that sucks but why
are you coming into work so late it's
almost like you spent the night
somewhere i don't know like maybe the
bartenders wait what how did you know
that because aubry is my friend and she
was the real setup all along no no no no
no yes i knew you'd reject whoever i put
in front of you i mean trishelle was
just a decoy and you fell for it hook
line and skinny margarita nicely done
aubry is great we are going to dinner
again tonight i owe you an apology
you're a great matchmaker thank you and
you know what i'm just glad that you
found the courage
to tell me how great i am it means so
much whatever
have a fun day
so
are you bringing someone to the wedding
no i'm taking a break from dating for a
while what i'm sick of asking people how
many siblings they have oh is it
somewhere between zero and two how
fascinating but you never know when
you're gonna find your dream person
anyone on the street could be
that all right it feels like you googled
how to talk to your bisexual friends
yeah
the point is you can close yourself off
all you want the universe will find a
way that is the stupidest thing i've
ever heard cars here
hi i'm here to pick up rosa are you the
one i'm looking for
all right she should be here any minute
her name is alicia switch with me
that's your good side i have a bad side
oh damn you didn't know all right can we
just focus on finding the veil really
it's not a big deal i'm sure it's in her
car
oh there she is do you mind if i slyly
mention you're single do not do that you
won't even notice hey you needed to see
me again rosa's single what ignore him
we left a dry cleaning bag in your back
seat oh uh i didn't see anything but you
can take a look
the veil's not here rosa we're so
screwed hold on don't freak out
[Music]
rosa what the hell are you doing what
you were the one that said that was
before the bear went missing when life
was breezy
so i only had one passenger after you
and he got off here well what did he
look like i don't know i mean he was
wearing some dumb hat i'm sorry i know
that's not helpful all hats are dumb
what the hell is that your laugh also
quit vibe and help me solve this sorry
man that's what the universe wants screw
the universe the universe is a dick
maybe it fell out when he got out of the
car wow you're so smart oh yeah yep yeah
there it is
uh oh
it's kind of dirty looking but yo that's
why they put it in a dry cleaning bag
i'm sure everything inside is totally
nope soaked in urine
damn it new york
i can't believe it's taken so long for
us to meet you're so nice oh i don't
know about that jaw sign i'm just being
myself well you're very sweet about the
cosmetology thing a lot of people are
dismissive of hair stylists it makes no
sense if we didn't have hair stylists to
cut our hair our hair would be far too
long wow great compliment hey
you're the girl from the diarrhea
commercial aren't you you get diarrhea
on the plane that's not true yeah move
along i don't get diarrhea on the plane
i get diarrhea in the airport
what's going on
are you
an actor well you don't have to sound so
grossed out i can see why you didn't
want him meeting jocelyn excuse me this
isn't jocelyn it's sheena she's an
actress yeah i was in an episode of svu
i say we want answers the director tried
to replace me but marishka said it would
take too much time and then they all
agreed i'd probably cut together fine
look tears i've obviously misread our
relationship you didn't want me to meet
the real jocelyn because we're not as
close as i thought we were so
message received
hey so you don't by any chance need any
molly do you i'm a cop and seen now i am
out of character and i don't sell any
drugs i am leaving
excuse me do you have a less crinkly
dollar i could trade you for no of
course i do none of my dollars has a
single crinkle when they do i steamed
them oh
wow that is crisp i can't wait to get
this baby home and flatten it out
almonds nice joys oh thanks they're uh
they're not for me they're for my
girlfriend detective diaz oh
you must be jocelyn what no i'm denise
who's jocelyn is rosa cheating on me oh
my
no that was a joke i'm sorry i thought
it would be funny i am jocelyn
oh
that was actually very funny i didn't
know what was happening and then i
thought i knew what was happening but
what i thought i knew was happening
wasn't what was happening it's very good
you must be captain holt hey hey uh can
you give us a second babe yeah wait out
there pleasure to meet you captain
so this is jocelyn i'm glad you got to
meet her for the record i wasn't keeping
her from you because i was afraid you
were going to hurt her feelings by being
judgey i think it's hilarious when
you're judgey it's because i was afraid
you weren't going to like her you and i
are close and i
i value your opinion well she seems
great and our limited interaction maybe
you could get to know her better over
kevin's rice this weekend that would be
great
you might want to save your girlfriend
she's talking to hitchcock damn it
hitchcock
you